-Now, Magic, you spent
your career in the sports world
both on and off the court
and you have an eye for spotting
the best talent
for any given situation.
So we're going to play a new
game where you do just that.
It's time for
"First Draft Pick."
Here we go.
♪ -First draft pick ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Alright, bud. Here we go.
First up, who would you rather
get into an Uber pool with?
Stephen A. Smith
or Charles Barkley?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if I got in
with Stephen A. Smith,
I wouldn't get a word in
edgewise.
So I'm probably gonna go
with Charles Barkley.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. Alright.
That's a good answer.
-And remember this, Jimmy.
With both of us, it's got to be
a big Uber car now.
[ Laughter ]
-With Charles and Magic in it...
-I was going to say, Stephen --
-...can't be no little car.
-Stephen will fit in
a little bit easier, but okay.
I see what's up.
Okay. You need to
deliver a rousing pep talk
to your Pee Wee football team.
Will it be
Leslie Jones or Lisa Leslie?
-I'm going with Lisa Leslie
'cause I know she's a champion
and she will deliver
a great speech.
She's smart
and a good friend of mine.
So I'm gonna go
with Lisa Leslie.
-Alright. Oh, this is a good one
right here.
Magic, you're on the road.
You got to order pizza.
Domino's or Pizza Hut?
-Oh, man, that's easy.
Domino's all day long.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Come on! What?!
Oh, even my audience?!
What are you talking about?!
You got to go with the Hut!
-Nah, Domino's all day.
-Oh, my God!
-All day, man.
-You're in court,
contesting a parking ticket.
Who do you want as your lawyer,
Phil Jackson or Bobby Knight?
-Well, wow!
Because Bobby Knight
would cuss everybody out.
[ Laughter ]
And Phil Jackson
is really smart.
So I'm gonna take Phil Jackson
'cause he's gonna get me off.
I know Phil Jackson
will get me off.
-Yeah, Phil Jackson
will get you off,
but Bobby Knight might
throw a chair or something.
Do we have a video?
[ Laughter ]
Here's my man.
Hey!
[ Laughter ]
That's my jam.
Oh, this is an interesting one
here, Magic.
You can only wear one type of
shirt for the rest of your life.
Turtlenecks or V-necks?
-Wow!
And, you know,
I'm a fashion dude, too.
-I think I know the answer.
I'm gonna circle it.
I think I know your answer.
-I'm going to go with, though...
Turtlenecks. I'm going to
go with turtlenecks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Check it out!
I said -- I knew turtlenecks.
Alright, this one's a tough one.
You have to play one song
to pump up a crowd
at a Lakers game.
Do you choose "I Love L.A."
by Randy Newman
or "California Love" by Tupac?
-Oh, you know,
"California Love," Tupac.
Dang, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to go with Tupac
all day long.
That's my man.
The greatest
that's ever done it.
Hey, it's like your band,
the Roots, over there.
They're the best
that's ever done it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, they have a good [Clears
throat] teammate as well.
You know? It's like --
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Last question.
You're down by 2 with 2 seconds
left in the game.
Who do you want
taking the last shot?
LeBron or K.D.?
-Oh, man!
-This is going to
rock the sports world.
This is going to
-Yikes!
Oh, man!
Now, you know K.D. is a scorer
and one of the greatest
that we've ever seen
at that position.
But I got to ride the winner,
too.
I got to ride LeBron because he
got more championships than K.D.
-Wow! That's unbelievable!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You heard it here first.
Magic, you're the best, buddy.
It's always great to see you.
-You too, my friend.
-That was "First Draft Pick."
My thanks to Magic Johnson.